hallo mein name ist luca und ich hab
euch bei twitter gefragt ob ihr bei
irgendwelche fragen wird wir reden mit
dem clever bot ich habe bei twitter
gefragt ob ihr irgendwelche fragen kennt
die ich den clever board stellen soll
deswegen fangen wir direkt an mit bin
ich ein guter youtuber wurde mir auch
mehrmals geschrieben dass ich das denn
zu setzen ja oder nein frage an das
mache ich gut
videos mister clever bot könnten sie mir
dass eventuell beantworten das würde
mich definitiv sehr sehr freuen wenn
dieser bastard alltag kommen wir zu
einer anderen frage die mir auch ein
zwei mal gestellt wurde kommt kontrakte
incubus rein da ist ja derzeit das
voting da findet ihr auch normal kann
link dass das ist geil clever aber
trotzdem wird da ziemlich einfach die
frage beantworten dass du mir nicht
einfach die frage beantworten herbort
also äpfel hörst du mir überhaupt mal
irgendwann in einem schrank
so komme ich in tube clash rein sagt mir
das doch einfach clever bot es ist ja
jetzt auch nicht so schwer dass er
entweder ja oder nein beim portier nicht
glaube ich auf platz elf oder zwölf oder
zehn und ich muss in die top ten kommen
sollen die zuschauer auf den link in der
beschreibung klicken
lieber clever wort kannst du mir diese
frage wenigstens beantworten wenn jetzt
der ist ja fast schon so schlimm wie
sehr ihn denn da jetzt auch wieder
konnte ich hab die leider nie verstanden
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich das
richtig verstanden habe
ach komm fakt ist schild am ort mit dir
ohne spaß wie so mache ich das wieso
unterhalte ich mich mit dem clever botes
ist keine unterhaltung bastard
eine andere frage die mir auch
aufgestellt wurde gibt es ein hörner und
wenn darauf dass für einen weg sah mein
café mich jetzt getrunken
wo ich mich jetzt nicht kommt schon gibt
es ein hörner man irgendwann bringe ich
dich noch um ist mayonnaise ein
instrument wurde mir ebenfalls sehr auf
twitter ich weiß dann halt auch immer
nie wie ich auf solche etwas reagieren
soll
ich bin immer kurz davor meinen pc
einzuschlagen ist bei lese auch ein
instrument körper björn patrick weil
dieses keine somit ja endlich eine
antwort die mal gut danke du kannst ja
doch noch etwas mann ist das schönes
auch endlich kommt eine vernünftige
kommunikation zustand wieder zu anfangs
frage komme ich in die top ten bei
youtube clash dem youtube channel
wieso soll ich das dir sagen ich weiß es
nicht du bist der allwissende clever pro
jahr oder nein
die eine oder alle zwei jahre oder auch
nach auch du [ __ ] mach mir noch
einfach um diese scheiß antwortet flury
ist cooler als du kleine miss teen alter
wer ist genial meinte sie
warum liegt hier eigentlich stroh clever
bot kannst mir das vielleicht erkennt
dass er lass mir doch ein
niemals aber aber aber djokovic mit ihm
konnten das ist doch nicht wahr wie
scheiße wieder verarschen
wie sollen sie heißen eisenberg heißt
lasst uns bitte weiter
doch ich kann wieder ab lasst uns bitte
bei deutsch bleiben finde ich gut ok
schildermaler weiter mit der nächsten
frage was ist besser als eine paprika
falls ihr nicht wisst worauf ich mich
grad hier verlinkt ihr euch hier mal das
video das ich kann wieder nicht richtig
zeigen
da ist das video verlinkt wo ich das
sage mit
das ist besser als eine bakterie das
video fand ich werde das witzigste video
was hier hochgeladen also bot was ist
besser als band what the [ __ ] ist man
wenn man man bei google ein gekommen
das ist auf jeden fall gilt alte dm
lifestyle auf jeden fall sehr brady hier
wtf is mantega clever bord was willst du
in den himmel als ob du mit solchen auch
clever war die echt mehr von dir
erwartet was beziehungen angeht eine
weitere frage die mir aufgestellt wurde
war was ist der größte fehler gottes und
wenn clever bot jetzt
mein projekt schon die ganze zeit seht
ihr das wenn ich mich gerade ein paar
kratzer hast du eine freundin
das ist doch clever bot mir sah clever
clever bot sag mir den größten fehler
gottes bitte clever bord bittet dann
internet zu einem lover eine simple
minded wie so rieping sie dann einfach
auf englisch zu reden nun die frage auf
die wir alle gewartet haben lieber
clever bot was ist 0 geteilt durch 06